hi guys I'm Greg Alba and I'm John
Humphrey did you see our Joker teaser
trailer reaction you really should
because we're about to break down this
trailer I'm excited to go into this a
couple of things that I wanted to
mention breezing through the comments
I've seen a couple of similar things
being pointed out everyone's comparing
Joker right to like the other Joker's
already comparing walking Phoenix to
Heath Ledger or Jared Leto I'm like well
he looks amazing in this trailer yeah he
looks incredible yeah before you try to
decide who's number one in your book you
should probably wait to watch the actual
movie first that's just her safest bet
the other thing is - I see people kind
of come you know talk about the idea of
like giving the Joker an Origin because
a big carpets made him work in film
mediums and television mediums is not
really knowing what his origin is my
point to that would have to be it
doesn't really bother me here only
because Warner Brothers has strongly
pitched this as this is not directly
connected to the DC EU that this is its
own little venture its own little thing
if this was connected like if this was
the Jared Leto replacement I might be a
little bit concerned for something like
this where they only have a little bit
of backstory to borrow from because
there's obviously some Killing Joke
inspirations in terms of him being a
stand-up comic who descends into madness
they have that yes there is no ace
chemicals involved in his origin it
seems like at least like a lot of this
is very unique and a lot of this is
creative just original ideas because
there's not a lot of back story ideas to
truly draw from in terms of the comics
well yeah and we've seen a lot of
different takes and stuff over time so
for me as a viewer the Joker
specifically takes on this life where I
kind of take every take on the Joker as
its own take and yeah just the
definitive one because part of the fun
of the Joker is that it doesn't really
seem like there is a definitive one I
mean there are a couple that you can
point to for strong details but part of
the mystique of that character is yeah
the origin could perhaps be anything and
so as we go into this oh do you think
we're wrong about you disagree with a
theories that we miss please feel free
to comment below if there's anything you
think we just flat-out misinterpreted
feel free to share your opinions we'd
love to hear it anyway let's hop into
this so in the trailer stop the starts
they have this opening shot
which immediately reminds me of the
opening shot of the Dark Knight actually
and now the Dark Knight they shot that
in Chicago primarily for this movie I
heard they're primarily shot it in New
York and some stuff in Los Angeles but
it seems like the city streets
environment that they're borrowing from
here is most clearly New York City which
is perfectly suited especially because
of the vibes of like Scorsese films like
taxi driver and king of comedies it's
pretty fitting to have it be in New York
for this one well New York is one of
those cities it seems like it lends
itself to Gotham it's very packed and
tall and bustling and stuff like that I
almost feel like in LA or something
would be a bit too spread for a Gotham
City yeah and especially for a story in
the 80s that's dealing a lot with like
anti capitalism which is a big theme of
the 80s and movies in the 80s as well
we'll talk more about that later on in
the video
New York City is just the perfect
environment for that and they're right
at the center you can see there's a sign
says Gotham general right there that's
Gotham generally I thought at first and
said Gotham Central but taking a closer
look it says Gotham general and it would
just make more sense especially when you
go to the next shot which is with
Deborah Kane who in the comics is
actually a social worker for Child
Protective Services in here she's saying
to him does it help to have someone to
talk to and based off this trailer looks
like in the beginning of Arthur flexuz
journey that he's genuinely seeking help
for the emotional and mental issues that
he's going through in the story yeah he
looks like he's struggling with mental
illness and just trying to get a grip on
that there's a line that he says in this
trailer that seems to be such a
character theme throughout and it just
of course goes into play from the
beginning to end and it's super Joker
ish you know we're Joaquin's Arthur
flexo's my mother always tells me to
smile and put on a happy face she told
me I had a purpose to bring laughter and
joy to the world this is just me or is
it getting crazier out there now this
smile symbol is just there throughout
the whole trailer in his jokes notebook
there's one clear line you can make out
towards the bottom of the page that says
the worst part about having a mental
illness is people expect you to behave
as if you don't and there's a smiley
face with inside of the circle of dough
it seems like a lot of this storyline
that as he's descending into madness is
whenever he's experiencing pain he's
gonna be doing things to force a smile
to block it and I've always been
fascinated with that just in life we
live in LA or a big part of our culture
out here is you know there's lots that
would turn into some kind of at least
character exploration of light sometimes
you can't just paint everything with
positive thoughts and hope it's all
gonna be okay you know and I hope that
this movie really it seems like from the
structure of this trailer that the first
part of it is gonna walk around in his
mental state as a mental patient perhaps
or at least somebody's struggling and
yeah the ways in which he tries and
fails to cope with it one phrase I
always flashes - - situations like this
is you can't build your house on the
sand
eventually the house will sink you need
a good foundation I sort of see that
happen all the time with people who have
a lot of emotional mental struggles who
just try to block it all with positivity
but then before you know it they crack
they relapse they explode so from a
psychological standpoint I'm really
really drawn to this specific element
especially for my personal viewing
experience of course with a smile coming
into hand the song smile the smile came
from modern times it was the Charlie
Chaplin movie it's actually like an
instrumental suite that was then
repurposed I think the version in this
trailer is by Jimmy Durante but I'm not
entirely sure but yeah I mean it's a
classic
there's modern times literally
referenced you later on in this trailer
so I obviously the smile motif comes
back in the song but also modern times
is a comment on industrialization and
you know the rising just capitalism and
things like that you know workers rights
and things and that looks like a heavy
undertone to this movie - so it's just
another layer deep of that yeah illusion
and metaphors I love where they kick off
with the song of the line of dialogue
the lyric of the smile through your
heart is aching even though it's
breaking and the whole song is basically
about no matter the problems keep on
smiling so it's perfectly suited for
this trailer yeah so glad it just wasn't
some cool cover yeah it's because of how
much of a tone juxtaposition it is like
it helps that the irony is really on
point there with the title the song the
sentiment of the song etc yeah and then
you get some images of him taking care
of Francis Conroy who is a reoccurring
actress on American Horror Story she's a
great character actress across the board
and Everybody Loves Raymond is a
reoccurring character even this so she
has range yeah this feels reminiscent of
several things my mind immediately
flashed you in King of Comedy how De
Niro's character does live with his mom
and he's a comedian who really wants to
make it onto a talk-show you do get some
like Norman Bates vibes Travis Bickle
obviously and this just because I saw it
recently parts of this reminded me of
you were never really here because in
that movie - he's like living with his
mom and leaving her and they have like a
very intimate relationship and in that
movie he is struggling with mental
illness and violence and things like
weirdly this reminded me a lot of that
movie just in a different context I was
same way before this trailer even came
out today that if Joaquin Phoenix did a
hybrid of you were never really here
meets the master you'd probably get a
perfect performance here and you do see
shades of both of those and and just
this trailer alone no later on the show
you see him he's this being assigned to
earlier as his job he's dressed in his
clown makeup he has a sign holding that
says everything must go and then in the
later shot you can see that inside of a
music shop of sorts that it says
everything must go so maybe the stores
closing down maybe this plays a factor
in - Arthur reflects life at the time
you know you see shots later on where
he's in a locker room he's getting
dressed he's putting on makeup I'm kind
of thinking that maybe this music shop
has people perform every once in a while
so maybe they would have liked some
dressing room upstairs or something or
maybe he works for a sign twirling
agency that has multiple people twirling
around town or something yeah perhaps
you know you do see in the shot -
outside of the store there's a person
playing on a piano but anyway back to
the sign looks like some punks I decided
to take his sign steal from him and he
starts running after them and and I feel
like there's some symbolism happening
here and I also think this scene is
probably later in the movie than how
this trailer is actually advertising it
they take the sign and they hit him over
the head with it and in the next shot
he's kind of cowering like a child on
the street and he's holding his crotch
where looks
we kicked him in the nuts I'm in the
nuts I feel like there's some symbolism
there because when you piece together
the trailer it could be later on in the
movie because in a later part on the
trailer that's when he's on the subway
station he's wearing the same outfit and
makeup that's when he starts to crack
that's when he starts to really look
like he's really breaking that looks
like that the fining scene of where he's
just laughing maniacally on a subway
station and crying I mean it looks like
he's oscillating he's really is on the
edge there like this scene right here it
could be the scene
prior to that moment I feel like there's
some symbolism there with having a sign
that says everything must go
hitting in on his head you know mental
illness breaking it and he's breaking
down let the sanity go and just give in
to all your pain and all your trouble
this is a coincidence or maybe that's
direct symbolism on Todd Phillips Park
yeah well and there's also I think a an
economic at least nod in that because
it's a store that's going out of
business and there is all this civil
unrest over capitalism and the predatory
nature of that so I'm sure that it yeah
relates to the time and place this movie
wants to be in - well that's why I was
thinking he does work for that music
store in the store shutting down so not
only does he have all these struggles
but now he's out of a job now here's a
fun Easter egg that took a little bit
too much research but it was worth it
for this one thing yeah in the next shot
you see Arthur dancing with his mom I
did read one comment which I couldn't
find again part of filming this video
someone's saying that he thinks like the
moms like gonna die a little bit right
after that scene basically but basically
when they're dancing they're there the
televisions on there's a credit to say
written by and we looked at the names of
everyone who was listed there a few of
those names are actually people who are
directly involved with this movie you
see the name Michael asura who is the
assistant art director this movie will
limpert who's the production secretary
then gotta Lauri
who's the travel coordinator assistant
production coordinator for this second I
saw a boy this has to be some sort of I
thought I was gonna be like Batman stuff
like oh that's actually even kind of
cooler like really acknowledging your
crew putting their names in there I
thought was pretty neat well if they're
all listeners writers I gotta wonder if
they're all people who like if they just
finished an episode of Robert De Niro's
show you know or something like that cuz
it looks like it's late at night it
looks like it's part of the talk-show
element and an establishing shot of the
donut store first thought there's an
awful lot of trash out front clean up
those streets I have never seen so much
trash out front of a rat of a restaurant
yeah like so much trash right there
there's a couple of things I notice it
says it's on Jerome Avenue which is a
real Street in New York
I don't know how detail-oriented they
care about that like oh there could just
be another to Rome Street in Gotham City
or maybe this really is New York and
Gotham's close to New York or something
but I also thought it might be in cool
tribute or memories reading so much into
it too camera Monaghan's Jerome
portrayal of the Joker on Gotham another
thing I noticed like I said this I could
just be reading so much into this but
there's obviously a lot of Scorsese
vibes here the crosswalk sign also says
don't walk which could have a deeper
meaning for the characters it could be
referring to as Ozzy Beats character of
like don't get involved with this guy
because there's a scene in Goodfellas
with the Lorraine Bracco character Karen
basically she's confronted with a choice
to walk into some place and then camera
tracks up and then in front of the
camera appears the crosswalks line don't
walk which was it's been talked about as
like direct symbolism to her choice in
that moment so I don't know maybe it's
just a crosswalk sign or maybe Todd
Phillips want her to pay even more
tribute you know and then of course they
you know that doughnut shot moment that
is with za z beets he plays a character
named sufi Du Monde she is described as
a cynical single mother and Arthur's
love interest so you know that's gonna
turn out well I don't know if they're on
a date or if he's just friend-zoned at
this moment I get more of that vibe
either way it's just a tender moment it
seems like one of the actual bright
spots of yeah movie potentially and it
looks like perhaps one of the few
positive elements of Arthur's life
probably represent a good amount of the
debate of this movie if there is one the
next shot we see Arthur of Lucky's
crossing the street to the Arkham State
Hospital which when you are doing
researches I'm like wait a minute why
isn't this called asylum
sigh Lumia I mean it's an outdated term
by today's standards and you know
probably by the 1980s it would have been
I mean they closed a lot of the old
school like mental asylums down they
probably just rebranded it to fit the
times I feel like it makes it feel more
realistic too it makes it easier to
establish it's not connected to the
direct DCE yeah there's a shot here that
maybe just has his character meeting
nothing like too heavy plot wise I
really like that shot where Arthur's
riding the elevator and right next to
him there is a patient who is just
clearly losing his [ __ ] you know and
next to them you see a you know a
security guard or a warden and then an
orderly who are take your transferring
this patient to wherever they're
transferring him to but I think it's a
cool sort of symbolic moment for the
character of Arthur he's going to his
place where clearly people are getting
treated for the criminally insane and I
don't know if he has some criminal
background established in this story
his whole journey it seems like as he
just wants to be normal he just wants to
be happy he wants to be healed here is
cornered into this tight environment
being forced to have to be right next to
this energy the same people who are
treating this guy are treating him you
know that's a great visual juxtaposition
just juxtaposition of his struggle in
general because he looks so tense like
he's just trying to hold it together and
I feel like that's probably just a
larger metaphor for his character
because right over his shoulder is the
insanity we do you see Brian Tyree Henry
will go back to him just a little bit at
the next shot he's watching a stand-up
comedian performing at a place called
pogos Oh would you instantly put
together
oh yeah cuz poco is the clown alter-ego
Pogo the clown was John Wayne Gacy which
is you know one of our most infamous
serial killers and yeah that makeup even
that he's wearing I've got the photos
and you're much of the trailer is very
reminiscent to Pogo the clown yeah and
we found this quote that's Gacy once
said that acting as a clown allowed him
to regress into childhood so it just
seems like more than ever especially
with the footage that a big part of the
inspiration for this psychotic version
of the Joker could be drawn directly not
just from you know inspirations of the
comics and inspirations of
Scorsese films or something but from
real-life serial killer John Wayne Gacy
what's cool in this trailer he's got
he's got a couple of different laughs
here I know we were talking about it how
that laugh may seem ADR from a different
moment but based off what the trailers
communicating I love that laugh in that
particular moment and especially with
the body language there because he's
sitting alone he's listening to the
comics he's seen that he's being loved
like the comic is being loved and it
just seems like a laugher he's kind of
trying to blend in he's trying to fit in
feel like he belong as a part of
something like it seems so forced like
he doesn't really find this funny but
he's trying to that's actually one of my
less favorite moments of this trailer oh
really
I don't know this is completely
speculative on my part it feels like
they went we need a joker laugh
somewhere in this trailer this is the
most appropriate place to put it
cuz to me it feels really out of place
the way he's laughing and it doesn't
look quite natural to me for some
reasons I kind of feel like it's forced
but in the wrong direction huh but I got
you know we'll see whether you come
marble shell that's right man captain
Marvel's out now go see it people let's
come back to em over talked about
earlier is cracking on the subway and it
looks like some you know Wall Street
[ __ ] types
yeah and it's movie in the 80s and a big
part of the 80s did represent like
corporate greed anti capitalism even in
a later shop with some of the protest
moments with the clowns holding signs
there's one very clear sign from a very
specific clown that says anti-american
anti-capitalist a job as a right
capitalism does not work for you and
there's other images too that reflect
that based off what happens later on in
the trailer that will go into of certain
lines of like Thomas Wayne says these
guys beat him up and this could be a big
part of why it seems like a big victim
of the Joker's will be someone who is
like one of these Wall Street kind of
guys you know one of these big corporate
kind of guys I imagine that maybe these
guys have something to do with helping
him descend into that direction well
that's a part of this trailer that makes
me the most curious because it is kind
of the most vague to me about this is
kind of a chicken and an egg thing about
there's clearly the clown imagery is
tied to the
citywide protest this movement of swords
and so I'm sitting here going did the
Joker somehow spark off an
anti-capitalist movement or is he
co-opting the image of this to further
instill chaos you know where where do
all these elements fit together and
that's an aspect of this I wasn't
expecting was some kind of social
commentary kind of like you would see in
the 80s and and also very relevant now
too
part of what I'm getting from this
because they do see Thomas Wayne on the
screen you hear his line and that actor
was actually in The Dark Knight Rises
because when you're seeing the protest
you're seeing others dressed up in the
clown aesthetics
Thomas Wayne says Gotham's lost its way
what kind of a coward would do something
that cold-blooded someone who hides
behind a mask so it's very apparent at
least what I'm gathering from the
trailer like my my basic theory goes
something like this
so Arthur Fleck is struggling stand-up
comedian you see an image later on and
here where he goes up on stage he's not
in clown makeup or anything like that
but you know when he does the twirling
signs gig he is in clown makeup and such
so it seems like at the point of when he
cracks I imagine he probably kills
someone very important maybe some big
corporate guy maybe some big politician
perhaps but he does it not with not in
clown makeup being revealed but wearing
a clown mask because that's specifically
what thomas wayne is saying you see a
lot of people donning pretty much the
same kind of masks you even see a shot
later on in the trailer where he's
walking through the subway he takes off
the mask and throws it in the trash so I
imagine he probably kills someone
wearing the clown mask or it could be
something along the lines of what you're
talking about where this revolution has
already started him partaking in it he
decides to murder someone using that
image right then I imagine that he
starts to embrace because these are the
the whole the whole thing with the clown
revolution image seems like this is a
revolution for the people so an aiding
in his stand-up bit I think he starts to
applied makeup on himself it makes me
think of like when Steve Martin first
started to in stand-up comedy
he's too dressed kind of silly then to
make his act funnier he just started
wearing a suit and looking like a
regular guy and it's kind of an opposite
effect here instead of looking like a
regular guy he's embracing the people
and start sporting clown makeup onstage
which have been
surely leads to him being a big comic
he's relating with people and then lands
him on the talk show that you see Robert
De Niro was hosting or it could be the
opposite where he kills someone before
any of this revolutionist stuff is
happening obviously this already and
obviously there's already a lot of anger
with the people so it could be he starts
the whole clown mask revolution he
starts that whole symbolism by killing
someone instead of people being like
who's this murderer people like he did a
good thing he was right we're all gonna
dawn the clown mask now weird vigilante
hero exactly it could be it could be one
of the other either way he kills someone
I imagine first wearing the mask because
you do have that shot too later on
where's a close-up on the guns already
been fired it's going off so maybe he
broke into someone's office and killed
that person so yeah there's people
protesting outside of Wayne Hall at this
moment Arthur if like you see him
rolling down the stairs but he's not in
clown makeup and he's not wearing a
clown mask so perhaps you're probably
closer to that theory that people
already started wearing the masks
beforehand then you see this Bruce Wayne
moment where he's he's pretty much
trying to lure him in it's kind of like
know if any link it's actually gonna
like sexually abuse the kid but it does
kind of get there we shouldn't put your
figures in a boy's hand yeah but it's
also very in tune with the symbolism of
what the smile stands for here it could
be one of two things he's trying to lure
his way inside of Wayne Manor but the
fact that he gives him those you know
clown like prop flowers the Bruce Wayne
looks incredibly sad and the whole theme
of him blocking depression and pain with
a smile is probably after the moment
when Thomas Wayne and Martha Wayne had
been murdered presumably by him yeah the
whole ending moments are all cut to make
it look like he's pretty much getting
ready for the talk show yeah yeah and no
way I mean you see some like origen
moments when he's first applying the
green hair which is it cool like I like
putting on the dye moment yeah but then
the talkshow moment you know yeah I get
a couple of things here that I lost you
the King of Comedy reference for sure
like that's just straight out of the
King of Comedy also to have DeNiro in
the in the position that Jerry Lewis
played at it was pretty neat well I
wonder if that might even become some
kind of hostage situation because
they've been pretty upfront about that
King of Comedy like that yes getting
included so I wonder if he's
make like a public scene on TV or
something now he's got the platform it
also could be partly inspired by in the
Dark Knight Returns comics in which the
Joker he is being treated for mental
illness a through Arkham I believe it
could be either way he's gained true
through the mental illness and then he
goes on a talk show and hopes to be
welcome back to the public I don't
imagine it's the same intent I think
he's just going there to do comedy yeah
is they would have let a guy who's like
this guy murdered a politician we're
gonna bring him on the show no I don't
think they do that yeah there's just
some other quick moments you know the
last most of the trailer Arthur's
running down the hallway in the Arkham
Hospital and this could be the moment
earlier when Brian Tyree Henry gives him
this really suspicious looking man
Arthur is like what any and in that shot
he's holding a portfolio probably like
documents of his past or mental
illnesses or history or something
exactly exactly as I obviously he broke
in and stole it and you know probably
got into a fight with Brian Tyree Henry
was credited as playing a nurse in this
movie so there's one shot here where I'm
kind of I'm very fascinated by because I
can't tell if there's an actual shot in
the movie you know yeah well it kind of
reminded me the the the big long stare
shot where he's like dancing and jumping
down and stuff like that and it kind of
reminded me of that makeup test the way
that is kind of dreamy in the way that
he's just sort of standing there and
straightening self out and then he
laughs a little bit and that had a
similar energy and I almost wonder if it
comes out of some kind of montage or
some kind of weird surreal sequence of
sorts well the cinematography to it does
in general kind of look dreamlike it
looks a little bit detached a little
disillusioned you know looks like a
reflection of his mental state yeah yeah
yeah the push yeah you know he's like
dancing on the staircase it could also
be a symbolic moment because there are
shots where he's walking up the stairs
at the very beginning of it and this
shot yeah and now that he's become full
Joker he's going down the stairs and it
could be a symbolism for descending into
madness where when he's walking up even
though he's not succeeding he's trying
to move up he's trying to move forward
and then the staircase going down he's
going crazy yeah won't even in the way
those
a shot because the first part of the
trailer when he's coming up it's a
closer angle it's almost like his head
is surfacing out of water or something
like that and then in the end the
staircase is in the wide we see his
whole body he looks were shooting from
below exactly powerful position to come
from you know that line I used to think
my life was a tragedy now I realize it's
a comedy that's just the whole theme and
they haven't perfect that's a perfect
line like there are good lines
difference between comedy and tragedy is
time very Shakespearean the two
categories he had right yeah anyway what
do you guys think of this joker trailer
leave your theories breakdown opinions
whatever you want in the comments below
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification Bell
check us out on patreon we've got plenty
of goodies a lot of exclusive content
it's worth your time kind of worth ours
not worth my mom's I'll see you guys
later